you said a modern female mentality is me
before the family right women file a
divorce we all know this what 70 to 80%
of the time especially if they're
College uh educated um divorce how do
you feel about divorce you said it
should be banned yeah except for except
for Will Smith I'll give him
one so Will Smith Will Smith I grant you
a divorce so other than Will Smith when
do you condone divorce under any
circumstances I'll give one ided abuse I
think if they're beating each other they
should like work it out they should just
both figure out how to not hit but yeah
one-sided abuse I'll give you a
divorce um maybe some adultery cases
most most cheating is a one-time thing
fun fact but you know um maybe if he
gets another chick pregnant I might give
you a divorce so there are exceptions to
the rule yeah yeah the church used to
like you'd have to like give your case
to the church and then they would say
yes or no but they were a lot more picky
back then so go Ham on the women right
now right I don't think you're going to
have a problem with that
um um what what is it that makes them
selfish why are they the ones filing for
divorce the vast majority of the time
what is it that they're just willing to
just Cast Away their kids their family
and just succumb to their emotions what
is it oh god I've heard every I'm sure
you've heard every excuse to he was
holding me back I'm like from what
he gave you kids um no I mean women file
70 to 80% of the time and a lot of times
I think it's because they think the
grass is greener on the other side um
and a lot of times again the media tells
us we're so special and awesome and
amazing and you're going to find better
and the truth is that most women do not
the majority of single mothers do not
remarry they do not it's um I think only
it's like 15% actually get a guy to
remarry them 22% get a guy to live with
them again so the majority of single
mothers do not have Happy Endings and
we're not really honest we don't really
tell people these statistics okay bingo
I think that's a great point and a great
stat you just made we just did uh a
whole panel Kevin Sao was on uh Troy
Francis was on a couple of our friends
were on there was a couple single
mothers on the panel uh Janelle Gordon
you might uh you might know Janelle we
asked the question to the men um you
meet this woman she's amazing she's
awesome she's young she's beautiful
she's charismatic she's smart you know
she's uh loyal all that fun stuff uh but
she has a three-year-old kid okay the
good news is he was potty train
y uh would you date this girl and
uniformly they're like nah nah n n and
then the women with kids obviously
stated their case that's like no like a
real man needs to step up all that fun
stuff but you said that only 15% of
single mothers Remar roughly I don't
remember if it's it's like a roughly 15
I don't it could have been 13 but I
think that's a important stat to point
out because if that's the objective yeah
to get married be good to know that stat
yeah and then 22% get a guy to live with
them but again that means the majority
do not have Happy Endings you know
another another stat if you hit 30 and
you're not in a relationship um you're
more likely to not have kids than to
have them as a woman as a woman okay
gotta well actually if you if you had 35
as a guy you only have a 15% chance of
getting married over I think too many
men like they see the game they're like
I'm not playing with this interesting
well I'm going to give you un to nitpick
my uh dating life in a second so we got
a few more things but you brought up J
pinket you said you know I'll make a few
exceptions for divorce uh but certainly
women should uh stick it out not file
for divorce um you'll make an exception
for for Will and Jada um know she has a
new Memoir call out called worthy um you
know we all know what happened with the
guy August Alisa years ago on the red
table talk if your wife if your wife has
sex with your daughter's if your wife
has sex with your your daughter's friend
I will give you a divorce yeah no doubt
we can agree he gets one right yeah
here's the book right here um you know
she has alipa I believe so that's where
B so in this book she describes her
romantic past that she was really in
love with Tupac uh they were actually
will and J were actually separated for
seven years uh and then obviously the
entanglement that you mentioned with
August alusa so what are your thoughts
on what's going on on with this if you
were Will's guidance counselor what
would you advise him and if you were
Jada's psychiatrist guy guide his
counselor what would you advise her's
going to play doctor right now I would
say Jada please stop torturing this man
just you need to be by yourself yes yes
it is time for you to die alone Will
Smith um I would also say you should
divorce her yeah this is this is just
craziness this is embarrassing to your
family she's going to keep doing this
she's going to keep making a public
spectacle out of whatever you guys go
through so why do you think he still
stays with her
um what do you think she has on him any
man that's been dis disrespected like
this emasculated like this has to look
in the mirror and be like I'm freaking
Will Smith maybe it's just go listen to
some Andrew Tate or Leonardo DiCaprio
speeches and figure it out why do you
think he hasn't done it yet Pearl you're
an expert you know maybe maybe it's just
Cheaper to Keep Her at this point like
that is a thing you know what I mean
it's like what's on the other side of
this don't they live separate already I
have no idea yeah I know I think they
said they're trying to get back together
I don't know why you would do that but I
think at this point he's just tired yeah
just tired of dealing with it and just
willing to just roll over and just play
dead basically and just yeah well and a
lot of guys a lot of guys have been
taught that their job is to make women
happy and the truth is women were never
happy I mean they've given us all of
these rights and we still find something
to whine about it's interesting that you
said be happy because you know Will
Smith uh famously has said is like it is
not my job to make you happy you have to
make yourself happy and when you figured
out you can come back to me and I I
don't know what she's dealing with right
now but it's very interesting this whole
Will Smith thing after all the
embarrassment I'll give I'll give him a
divorce it's almost like what what's the
thing where you um you fall love with
your captor what's that called what's
the syndrome Stockholm syndrome
Stockholm syndrome sort of something
like that going on here she's got some
sort of spell on him must be I don't
know no man will put up with that much
shame and ridicule and embarrassment and
be like that's my wife dog I don't get
it I don't get it and it can't be the
money because even if you have yeah
what's his what's his net worth hundreds
of millions of dollars I assume he had a
prenup even if not here's million for
you I'll keep 100 million dude it's Will
Smith there's something there she's got
some secret something on her some secret
yeah